do you want to do the same map and try
to win again or do you want to see the
other maps oh
winning idiots yeah winnings for maybe
people like you
i'd rather see the world
i want to travel wild west
i can't be that one i got to be a nathan
instead i can't be late
nathan i'll be molly the redhead from
ireland oh yeah take good care of my
other wife what wait why how are you why
are you look what are you why are you a
demon
oh [ __ ]
yeah baby i
am iron man
[Music]
oh jeez
i'm gonna just take us in now have you
okay but i had so many more bits
hey save and save them
um in my opinion this one's even harder
than the last one yeah that's where you
guys live london's mining town it is
birthplace
of demonic
we have watchers walk in the
neighborhood with pamphlets and stuff
every
[Music]
hey that's like this year except like 40
years ago
you
guys i found an expired protein bar
90 in ireland protein ferments
but he did it i mean i'm literally
eating it
i'm not hungry before i literally said
you must stop him before it's too late
as you were eating it too late man all
right welcome everyone welcome welcome
to the wild west i'm going for it i
think
you guys come here
you're all gone already i'm going in
here
i know what to do mr collectible on the
ground right here
crazy
better so uh the way this one works just
uh it's similar to the last one
basically once we start it once we
trigger the events to start this we'll
find keys they open these lock boxes and
we'll get books out of the lock boxes
that go to one of the buildings we're in
so either get to know the symbol of the
building like clothing store general
store yeah
little symbols on like clothing store
here has like a little hat
i have a jerry can what does that do i
think we have to burn stuff later on so
once we once we do the ritual with the
books on the altar then we take the
books up to a church and burn them
you know we're burning is this a hare
[Applause]
we're on normal difficulty
as this word level gets oh sorry bob go
ahead
may 21st 1852 not but 40 years ago
mary something terrible has happened
many of my group those who helped me in
red read reading the ritual reading
readying yeah i think that spelled
correctly i've been acting frankly over
the past two days and then last night
joseph strangled a man to death
i've never known him violent
but [ __ ] you know things happen
anyway i'm very worried about uh about
joseph i guess i've appealed to my
followers for calmness
love james what the [ __ ] is that no what
is that that's the weird
i i have a james note as well okay you
gotta do the voice
ah most apologize for not riding sooner
no things are changing in mercy we've
had so much fortune recently people
believe that it's tied to my discovery
in the mind and would hang on my every
word and action as if i were a prophet
of some kind i have a master following
the swords there is a great power in
these words and these symbols i know it
i feel it
i'm missing you both keenly i sometimes
wonder if bonnie remembers her father's
face
james i ordered guys guys breaking news
bulletin i also have a letter no
all right
mary
[Music]
i found elijah in the saloon with the
pickaxe and there was blood on his hands
and face the whites of his eyes were red
when i spoke to him he stared through me
people are running scared leaving town
saying that we have called up some sort
of a devil with the ritual i cannot
believe that i will not
james all right guys i found a note
we're being attacked what's happening
the demon is on us
okay dearest mary
from the mind john has filled no less
than ten small books every evening past
few days i've been looking over them i
believe they're poor
you're
hey i was nervously hiding in the closet
right next to that key i found that key
i don't know
it doesn't seem like you found that key
now did you
hit myself over here
[Laughter]
i found the church i'm a coming these
ladies
so fast
guys only got half a horsepower in the
church anybody got a church key
i just used it baby
[Music]
does anyone have matches i've got a
battery oh my god guys come look at this
rack what do you mean no guys
guys
james is here well hey come on look
wow
oh my god
you're right it looks like engineer mark
getting actually
that's weird i don't like that
all right what are we doing
finding keys opening lock boxes getting
uh
the matches the matches are for the
pentagrams we have to light the
pentagrams
however
only four of the pentagrams i think are
lit at a time and if they're glowing we
can light them if they're not glowing we
can't use them yet oh man you and your
words bob you look like someone who was
whose kid had to be dragged up into the
woods to be like i'll teach you how to
go son you're like dad [ __ ] i don't want
to be here
oh wait did someone read this note oh
[ __ ] what is that is that wrong
i'll read you another note he's not he's
not following we're fine it's fine i'm
sure it's fine [ __ ] dude if my head can
go well okay it's fine
do it
[Laughter]
gonna really punctuate the point
you gotta really bleed from the throat i
gotta i
why is my name censored
his name's bum
them stars oh my god
you almost just got me murdered
oh
[Music]
at least i [ __ ] read what are you
doing
guys i got great news i found another
note
no way
thank god
i'm free
right right
and it doesn't matter if we've heard it
you have to read every note you come
across new rules
dear
the love and abrasive you're born bosom
keeps me up with that
james
anyone read that everything is hellish
chaos has visited mary note what i can't
even remember anymore
i think we've i think i i have a big
book what does that do
alcohol
you have to put it on the chorus
whatever symbol it is nice you got a
pentagram it so what's the symbol in the
book
it's a bottle of alcohol what's the
jingle jingle
there's a big man is that james you need
to take that one did you find him did
you find james jordan
willie right there james is stimper
stomping all over town oh you to clink
and clunkering he's uh find the saloon
sean he's anchoring where's god's name
it's the saloon was down by where we
started yeah yeah i'm doing it already
it's uh it's in it's over here it's got
the saloon doors wall jam
did you find the wall with the saloon
doors yeah it said i need to put the
book down i need to light the candles
when the lights try to light candles it
says it's not ready
so just drop the book there and leave it
for now if the if that one's not lit we
can't do it yet yeah oh it's not the
balloon i mean
oh the big he's big hey he's over there
if he's over there i'm not i don't wanna
look out he's
where's where's alcohol bug though
because you were not in the saloon the
salinas
the saloon is right here it's a saloon
on it
you were in the other one what do you
mean
come in here you're not even looking at
the right person
you're the red haired lady how do i even
know who's talking down right next to
your [ __ ] saloon pentagrams right
here
you don't put it in there i can't he
said
nice
oh you're right the candles have to be
lit up yeah the magic straight line
counts with the button [ __ ] matches
hey hey uh wait can i light some candles
is that allowed
[ __ ] leave it yeah by all means all
right i'm just gonna light them all
right man you're okay this program is
not ready to be used
no the pentagrams are random we have to
do the first four and then like once
we're done with those then the next ones
light up what do you mean
what does that even mean
so here's the order of operations we
have to get the keys unlock a box we get
the book whatever the symbol on that
book is we take the book to that
building we find the pentagram
if that pentagram is glowing then that
means we can light the candles set the
book down the book will start to glow
once the book is done glowing we take it
to the church we burn it and then that
book is done that's the second instagram
let's just go home
can we just read funny notes i never
like james anyway i don't feel like
saving him anymore
james yeah [ __ ] james you look kind of a
dick if i'm honest i found a note from
james you just want to read it hi no
it's too long i changed my mind it's too
long
spare yourself hey is he around here
somewhere we can paraphrase
dear mirror paragraph james
oh this pentagram is gone
[Music]
what book is his i got a gun book
oh that's across here this is nc taylor
clothiers yeah the gun one's right here
i got gun
oh where are you man glow there are no
glow oh no drop the book here though how
do i drop the big fellow the big fellow
is outside the gun store he's going in
the gun
around the back hey if you guys are
outside the back of the gun store he's
going in that direction you're not
you're freaking out a lot i'm really
freaking out man you know how many times
i got grabbed and humped by spider last
time
you can't impart past experiences onto
future people you meet you can't project
like that that's really wisdom there the
way i said it was not wisdom
you can't project future use onto past
weez all right so
yeah i need
i'm where's the more books i'm trying to
find a book
rail
rail track outside
uh mine book
oh
dude that was sick
what happened guys i found a roof with a
hole in it do i want to go in that yeah
that is will get us into the town but uh
he can also take the shirt dude i've got
a spicy book oh yeah
already yeah i'll burn that [ __ ] where
where
skirts how was he cling clanking around
by me already what oh i circled back to
the town that's what had happened you
press g you can leave that gas here so
we have it for the next batch g you can
drop stuff with g if you have a book
that's uh glowing you do not want to set
it on the ground and the ghosts will
step will stab it they'll nab it they
might stab it definitely now what's up
there's ten
james get mad james gonna be well ghosts
okay
all right i'm burning it
you just laughed while you burned a book
yeah
yes yeah yeah what what's wrong with
that uh someone's grumbly out here it
sounds like he's out here he's near me
i'm doing a book pentagram thing i'm
just getting ready dude we out here i'm
sure he's near you because he sounds
like his grams will be glowing now since
we burned two books are we do we have
any books playing anywhere that we know
what is this now
who oh
now it's done now you're going now by
bernie
mama
you all right
it's unfair that's expressly unfair
it's classified now
he requires more saggers
when sam's eyes are red the uv will not
work that doesn't seem very fair at all
enjoy that book
i want to see you laugh while you do it
oh burn burn in hell you disappear
careful i'm being attacked watch out you
got a ghost uh where where are you
oh he's mad
i'm gonna stick with you so we get this
book dead i'm gonna stay with sean i can
see any friends he starts here
where's the whoa i don't think he is
did anybody get the book for the uh what
is it the sheriff's office the general
no i got
here i have the key for that and
channels must be lit can you give me a
light
you gotta laugh
nice nice nice
i don't like it
[Music]
[Music]
i'm inside the book area with the press
crab isn't that good
he's down he's good is that is that nice
how cold can he how calm does he need to
be
he won't be back home for very long well
i'm gonna go burn a book that should
calm him right down yeah that'll make
sure he stays calm he hates a good book
burning he loves it actually
he's walking into town oh it gets real
bright out when you burn books that's
interesting hmm
oh he's mad he's right in the middle of
town would he be mad ah
this is my stall don't come in
bob we might be [ __ ] no this is fine
it's fine just turn off your light he
won't it's kind of dusty at
his vision's based on lightness probably
his vision is based on gamma
he sees radio bass
are you guys okay
no no no no oh he's like stunned already
all right good
i don't know what to do right now what
do i normally do
not really i
don't know let's just move back to the
town i'm alive
oh you're actually dying
i don't know how this idiot died
okay look guys i like pointing to a
medkit for you i'm standing next to one
okay i'm coming thanks babe sorry if i
accidentally burn you on fire no no it's
okay
no that's so many ghosts yeah what's
with all the high
hey look at that extra res i have there
you go guys i'm lighting some candles
you ready i'm going to contribute
where's that where's the sheriff lock
box where's the sheriff lock box i have
the sheriff around to the right of the
building there's like a staircase like
an alley wave to go up and sit there oh
interesting i've tried to get to the
church
oh the ghost really loud sculpting man
with a gun outside most really impeded
my progress no no
how do i tell if my book is glowy
it really glows
ah there's a ghost inside the church
really glows
i don't think i have a glowy book guys i
think i could shot me from below this
down the steps
what oh he's uh sam's coming for the
shirt
oh hey man
how are you doing no look look look look
oh
i think he's looking
he looked right at it and he did not
care he was not uh concerned
his eyes were a glow his eyes weren't to
glow i just didn't have any batteries
there was a thousand ghosts are you dead
uh yeah pretty much i'm about to be very
dead because i'm getting mauled by
ghosts right click where's the stables
where's the stables that's
by the well
i'm going to the bottom of the hill bob
we're coming it's like a medpack right
here i already have one oh okay cool
there's a ghost behind you i got it
don't worry
dude you did not sir
i got it
you were worrying i got all right the
stables is at the other end of town mark
if you're the one with the book i also
have the mine key
have the mine oh my look that's that's
to the right for pokemon yeah show me
i'll unlock all the things and you can
get oh i see i see mine
[Music]
where's the stables
where's the goddamn stables i'm
completely off boys oh i see stables
um there's too many ghosts whoever's in
the church help
i have no uv light oh
we're fine they didn't come in here
probably except for that guy but he's
leaving
hey hey hey hey hey god back out
oh oh i'm here
no not me not like this help i'm struck
in the stables
probably more gas around i didn't
realize you could get it
yeah
yeah
gg oh god i'm doomed i'm out of you
if anyone needs them i'm taking them for
that gasoline
why didn't we just get someone's dying
in the middle of town yeah i remember
all the screaming i was doing and
helping i was too busy about that note
that james wrote which one there were so
many good ones the one that ended with
james
oh not a good one
i i found one battery and i couldn't
carry it
i just i was already full i just need to
unlock the stable lock box and then i
think we're pretty
unlocked across the board right
son of biscuits
stomp stomps
stomp he's running
he's headed
uh
where did he
sweet ass i'm gonna come revive whoever
that is who did thank you
i might not wait do you have so many
ghosts behind you that you're not at all
dealing with my [ __ ] belly hole
your belly hole hey mark i'm gonna i
just need a med kit i don't see any med
kits anywhere i see one but it's down
here by the big fellow oh no
uh hey i found a note from j oh there's
two med kits in the saloon and i'm
taking one of them
a ghost a ghost is pinned me
with my pawn upon and within
without
you doing great buddy i'm coming
hey
look if you can get the ghosts away from
you mark i can help you but with all
these ghosts what am i to do
you got a point what is it
what is a man to do all right where's
the stable lock thank you buddy
somewhere stable to the right
all right
stable
my dude you got enough yeah you got
candles you doing the are you doing yep
yep i'll run it up mine i've got the
mine book
yeah i don't know where that is still
i've not figured out where the vine is
yet like middle left i've got it oh
i'm gonna go burn he's burning wow
hang on
in the middle of town should i not burn
oh mommy do not burn last
there's a bunch of dudes around
that's not me
who's dead then is that mark i'm not
dead i'm not dead either i'm not but i
don't know i see who's
i'm all the way down by the gun store
i know is that you that's crawling
around
yeah yeah i'm trying to remind you
there's just a whole [ __ ] kind of people
everywhere
oh comment man i can't even see you uh
the book i don't have
i'm gonna help somebody i'm helping
already
i think wayne's done as well right we're
good right i'm down
no [ __ ] way is he right next to me
again are you [ __ ] kidding me
i wish the door would open faster
hey wait are there any med kits oh he's
so fast i'm coming buddy
i'm coming pal
we're we're watching wade mark come on
come on come on baby
i'm coming he's getting laid
i'll close the door
[Applause]
oh my god i'm getting eaten by ghosts
oh i have the saloon book in my hand
what are you talking about dudes
jesus christ
hey i found sam hey guys i think sam
could be distracted for about five
seconds dude saloon book is done
literally picking it up what are you
talking about we all think the saloon's
a different building i think saloon is
done
it says saloon on the building yeah it's
done
i haven't even happened of
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think i'm down in the saloon
i will help you we'll find out i don't
see it
i think i think i'm down right now when
we go to one of 17 buildings that we all
think it is
wait i think if you could come in the
saloon and get me away to the saloon oh
god he's coming up the saloon
he's leaving the saloon he's climbing
the saloon oh no he's in your saloon
not my saloon i thought my saloon was
done there's a ghost in this thing
jesus
he was right there you know right where
you revived me he was right there he
wasn't but i revived you oh okay well he
is was now i got the mind book though
i'm sure someone put fire on that they
didn't put fire on them man i love the i
love the mini game where the ghosts are
inside you when you shine your light
around and they die eventually
yeah
oh come on man
guys i think i'm down in the saloon
dudes looms done
all right new saloon who did
[Laughter]
enough about the saloon you guys in the
saloon
i'm coming to get you the oh god i'm
coming together
i got a med kit i'm coming i'm coming
i got you i got you sorry i'm on him
wow that was like there's a lot of glass
breaking up there oh
[Music]
i was so almost there man
i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
just running because there's ghosts
[ __ ] everywhere ninth book i think is
on the thing i've got the last name
the clothing the clothing ones here
yeah the clothing one i did get it's on
the pentagram on the ground it might
have gotten scooped up by a ghost but i
did it
the last two books are here i've seen
you guys to bring two gasses yes i have
gas i'm going to gas them up boys i'm
going for the revive i i don't have
gasoline i'm just in the church going
for the river i've got to find you i
appreciate
upstairs in the back you go in and then
you go upstairs
there's a staircase in the back
i don't see the the back staircase oh i
know i see it i see it i've got it again
oh don't worry mark i'm coming don't
worry mark you standing gas tanks
there might be some up here probably
that sounds bad that's a lot of glass
smashing
all right i got a minute what happened
the last book is in the alleyway the
smaller alleyway on the ground bob you
go for it i'll bring the gas camera
right behind you
sam's up here at the church i think he
left i see the book i see the book of
the book go for the book
just run for it oh he's here he's here
he's here holy [ __ ] okay i'm just gonna
get the black man i'm gonna die
no no no you're not
all right i'm going
okay these guys come to the church
which way church other side for sure
yep just run just run just run around
him
i'm going oh god there's
[Music]
oh god three of us are down
i believe he works he's heading towards
north uh
yeah let's just uh pretend like we did
have it
oh yeah
wow
[Music]
man good game guys
good game we did it i can't believe we
did it
i can't either
hey i got a token i got a token
i got a token
i i i think i'm seeing that i should
probably rev res more people
kill kill more ghosts
and i didn't look how did my
played problem ghosts you were number
one there and you revived most people
wow
yeah that's right
i did pretty good uh mark you staggered
sam twice
yeah
what did i do what did i do
not a damn thing you did great you all
did great we did great thanks it's
really hard to get down to nine books
and the first attempts pretty good
that's not me being uh uh patreonizing
what what what
uh uh
uh like subscribe for more ising
what happened to me
i think that's great i don't i don't i
don't know what did what happened listen
to it it's a podcast buy coffee
raishan's coffee let's do our podcast
watch in space
do bob things what about go my favorite
sports team guys
that one too okay
after distract will you listen to that
one too okay yeah
and wear cloak while you're listening to
all of them and drinking coffee
[Music]